[Music]
on this Tuesday night a deeply divided
America votes how people are feeling
about the fierce fight for control of
Congress both sides are so polarizing
the battle over mail-in ballots and the
power of attack ads should politicians
find a new way to try to persuade voters
just because it's hard doesn't mean it's
impossible firing back beijing's
response to
Canadian election
plus their bravery and selflessness were
often overlooked I didn't tell anybody I
was indigenous what these veterans were
denied
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight from Washington today
we Face an inflection point
one of those moments that comes around
every three or four generations
we know in our bones that our democracy
is at risk and we know that this is your
moment to defend it well I think if they
win I should get all the credit and if
they lose I should not be blamed at all
okay
that's former president Donald Trump
speaking in an interview with news
Nation tonight he and the current
president making final pitches to
American voters neither man is actually
on the ballot in today's midterm
election Donald Trump isn't even running
for office at least not yet but he is
still a dominating influence over the
Republican party as Americans go to the
polls Republicans are hoping they can
win enough seats to take control of
Congress from their political opponents
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are here for midterm elections
they're called midterms because they
happen in the middle of the four-year
presidential term and right now
President Biden's party the Democrats
control Congress but by just a razor
thin margin Jackson prosco our
Washington bureau chief is with me
Jackson the polls are now closed in a
number of states too early to give any
conclusive results any reports of
problems at the poll stations I think
the big picture takeaway is that things
went smoothly obviously there's a ton of
interest in these midterms 45 million
people voted in advance we saw lots of
lineups today but only a few problems
but the point is those problems are
already being seized upon by Republicans
who are looking to build a narrative
about election fraud and an
untrustworthy election specifically
Maricopa County in Arizona that's the
most populous County there and there was
trouble today with some of the voting
machines not reading ballots properly
now they fixed the issue but that didn't
stop Republicans from going to court to
seek an emergency injunction to extend
voting hours and of course they tried to
blame democrats for the Fiasco even
though the county is run by Republicans
and Republicans run the elections there
as well just a sense though of how this
is playing out and you were at a polling
station today what did people tell you
about what's motivated them to vote we
were out in a part of Virginia that's
reliably purple could go either way and
voters really seem concerned with the
overall fate of the country and of
course those kitchen table issues like
inflation like the economy and of course
women's access to health care take a
listen
the direction of the country politically
with the division is probably the
biggest underlying issue I have a
daughter so
for me it has been the pro-choice the
kind of restrictions that are being put
up was a big deal worried about the
future of the country
um I'm not I just don't want Trump
coming back let me just put it that way
inflation this actually is a top issue
it's everybody's just worried about
what's going on trying to keep prices
down a little bit make it easy for
everyone it's
uh where we're headed
you know because there's so many issues
that are at stake
that you know that we have to think
about everything
this isn't going to be over tonight
there are millions of mail-in ballots
that won't be counted for some time
Jackson that is not fraudulent it's just
the way things work but it could pose a
problem yeah it really could already
tonight we're seeing former president
Donald Trump sees upon those problems in
Arizona we are expecting it could take
up to two weeks to get a final count
there Pennsylvania is very similar could
take a week or more for final results
there and Donna you know that in this
lull while we're waiting for the final
results they're going to be claiming
there are problems that make the final
result untrustworthy yet we could not
know the balance of power it may not be
decided until December depending on how
things go in in that tight race in
Georgia Jackson thank you well in the
coming days we could be looking at a
different political picture here in the
U.S Canada's neighbor Ally and biggest
trading partner the Democrats are
fighting to hold on to control of
Congress and if history is any guide the
odds are against them Eric Sorensen is
looking at the potential outcomes and
what's at stake
Donna it comes down to arithmetic for
the House of Representatives all 435
seats are up for election it takes 218
to win control of the house the party of
the sitting president usually loses
seats since the second world war that
party has lost on average 26 seats and
from the results in 2020 the Republicans
only need to flip five Democratic seats
the Senate is even tighter effectively
at 50 50 with vice president Kamala
Harris casting the tie-breaking vote for
Democrats 35 Senate seats are being
contested with razor thin margins
expected in several of the states
Democrats could actually gain in
Pennsylvania but they could lose seats
that they hold in Georgia Nevada Arizona
historically Republican turnout has
outperformed pollster's expectations but
Democrats hope with so much at stake
that they will defy the polling this
time it's a choice
it's a choice between two very different
visions of America voters May cast out
Democrats largely because of inflation
the economy is number one but so much
more will change policies from climate
change to abortion rights even support
for Ukraine could end the Congressional
investigation of Donald Trump would stop
and Republicans with control of the
house will turn on Biden there will be
uh investigations probably immediately
into Joe Biden members of his
administration into his son and it runs
deeper than just the house and the
Senate Republican state and local
officials could win control over how
elections work with one goal in mind
says David Frum to elect pro-trump
weirdos to these jobs they will elect
many many of these people to run
elections in a way that is uh without
that is aggressively unfair and that
will set aside the will of the voters
and if they refuse to accept the results
from some states then you have a
disruption in democracy and you can have
just just pure chaos which is why
Democratic voters fear that democracy
itself is at stake truth no longer
matters
truth has been lost with these
folks last night on CNN speaker Nancy
Pelosi talked about the kind of politics
that led to the Hammer attack on her
husband it's really sad because it is um
a flame that was fueled by
misinformation Nancy Pelosi said please
don't Donald Trump meantime talked about
Pelosi called her an animal because I
think he's an animal too
and they cheered after tonight Nancy
Pelosi could lose her speakership and
Donald Trump's star could rise again
that's what's at stake Eric Sorensen
Global News
now in other news as we reported
yesterday sources have told Global News
investigative reporter Sam Cooper the
Chinese government was behind an
aggressive influence campaign during the
2019 Canadian federal election which
included funding a network of at least
11 candidates sources tell Global News
it's a threat Canada's intelligence
Services felt was so serious the Prime
Minister and select members of cabinet
were briefed our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson is with me Mercedes
how has the Chinese government reacted
to this story
that's right Donna it seems that both
the story and the prime minister's
response to it have registered with
Beijing hitting a nerve on Monday we
asked the Prime Minister about Sam's
story Mr Trudeau didn't mince his words
accusing China of playing aggressive
games with Canadian democracy and of
targeting Canadian institutions the
Chinese foreign Ministry spokesperson
hit back today during his Daily Press
Conference claiming China isn't
interested in Canada's Internal Affairs
and warning that Canada should quote
stop making remarks that are detrimental
to china-canada relations a long
editorial also appeared in a Chinese
state-controlled media Outlet condemning
the Canadian Prime Minister for accusing
China of interference and warning that
there could be consequences if Canada
continues to back what it labeled as U.S
controlled foreign policy
and what's been the reaction from
politicians in Canada
well conservative Foreign Affairs critic
Michael Chong released a statement today
accusing Beijing of interfering in
Canadian democracy and calling on the
liberal government to move faster in a
statement Mr Chong said the biggest
victim of these PRC intimidation and
interference operations is the Chinese
Community themselves calling on the
Trudeau government to quote do more to
protect the Chinese Community from the
prc's threats and to protect Canadian
democracy Now Allied countries like
Australia have chosen to bring in
updated laws that address concerns about
Chinese State interference including
modern counter-espionage legislation and
a foreign agent's registry and while the
Prime Minister has promised to do more
he has not given us any specifics on
what that could look like or a timeline
of when it might happen Donna
all right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thank you
this is National indigenous Veterans Day
in Canada coming up the Discrimination
these soldiers faced and why this day
means so much to them
voting is underway in the U.S midterm
elections it could change the balance of
power in the capital we're back from
Washington in a moment
[Music]
foreign
this ceremony is one of several that
took place today in honor of national
indigenous Veterans Day the event was
founded in Winnipeg in 1994 and has
since spread across the country
for decades an estimated 12 000
indigenous veterans who served in the
three major wars were not formally
acknowledged on November 11th Nito
Garcia spoke with several indigenous
surface members in BC to hear what this
day means to them
he was 16 years old playing senior
hockey Richard vadan's father Hector was
just a teenager when he traded in his
hockey jersey for a military uniform he
was quite the hockey player a young man
from the residential school system
suddenly on a path overseas he turned 17
in May of the 1940 and then enlisted in
the Rocky Mountain Rangers Hector's
service in the second world war came
after his boss fired him from his job in
construction they said there are people
saying why isn't an Indian working when
there's white men didn't need a job
vidan says his father married a British
war bride and decided the best way to
protect their children was to hide their
Heritage never telling them their first
nations from residential school
experience where he had contracted
rheumatic fever had been bedridden he
learned no matter how hard you work
um what you do you can't change the
basic element
skin color features the dad says he only
confirmed his ancestry as a member of
niskalnath band halfway through his 11
years of service when I was commissioned
as an officer in the Royal Canadian Air
Force in 68 that was only eight years
after
my relatives and myself had been given
the right to vote
exempt from conscription they
volunteered to serve while giving up
their indigenous status many indigenous
soldiers were denied the same benefits
as other returning veterans while their
Reserve Land was sold away and it wasn't
until 1995 indigenous vets were allowed
to lay wreaths at the national war
memorial on Remembrance Day First
Nations making are leaving to go into
Harm's Way from a third world country
without resources and coming back to the
same circumstance it's not that long ago
acknowledging that sacrifice and
Injustice is what November 8th is about
I didn't tell anybody I was indigenous
says veteran and Trauma counselor Joy
Dockery no health benefits no land to
call their own
still racism and discrimination no
houses to live in
so what was the thing that they did they
re-enlisted
in the Korean War Dockery now leads an
association for veterans so I found an
ad in the newspaper advertising for
summer employment for students so I
joined and this group is part of
Vancouver's remembrance ceremony
finally
recognizes the indigenous people
we are getting there but we haven't made
it yet it's a chance to to recognize and
understand all that that our people gave
and were not recognized for an
opportunity to honor the history and the
heritage
more and more veterans finally feel they
no longer have to hide nitu Garcia
Global News tawasan BC
we will have live coverage of this
year's Remembrance Day ceremony in
Ottawa at 10 30 a.m Eastern 7 30 Pacific
right here on global and on our website
globalnews.ca
back to school in Ontario ahead where
contract negotiations stand between the
province and its education workers
[Music]
Ontario Premier Doug Ford says his
government is back at the bargaining
table with what he calls an improved
offer for Education workers didn't give
any details but said the deal offers a
higher amount for the 55 000 union
members who walked off the job on Friday
you know it comes down to the art of
negotiations on both sides we have to
sit down there uh give a little on both
sides uh for the betterment of the
students of the parents and in the
low-income workers
schools reopened this morning after the
Ford government promised to rescind a
law it passed that imposed a contract on
the workers and banned them from
striking QP the union representing the
employees says it is still an illegal
strike position but will focus now on
renewed bargaining efforts
at the inquiry into the use of the
federal emergencies act there was
testimony today that Ontario's solicitor
general pitched the idea of organizing a
meeting with the protesters blockading
Windsor's Ambassador Bridge earlier this
year in return they had to immediately
leave the superintendent of the Ontario
Provincial Police testified officers
delivered a letter outlining that plan
to the protest organizers the night
before the bridge was cleared
the party atmosphere had certainly began
and again it was just very disappointing
that um the letter had little effect
Dana early testified that after the
letter was delivered the majority of
protesters remained on the bridge
Witnesses say there was no single
recognized leader of the blockade the
bridge was cleared on February 13th
before the emergencies Act was invoked
[Music]
and here is one of the most unique
voting booths in the world it doubles as
a bump on the International Space
Station so even from space American
astronaut Josh Casada he passed his
ballot
we're back from Washington D.C in a
moment
we know politics is polarized in America
and now it's made worse by a barrage of
political attack ads
John fetterman has a love affair with
criminals fetterman's plan keeps the
drugs flowing the Killer's killing and
the children dying Herschel Walker
Decades of violence against women guns
razor blades choking stalking he can't
be our Senator whose side were you on
the cops who defended our democracy or
the criminals who tried to overturn it
yes Lee Vega defended these guys who are
the Democrats bringing into our cities
and how many more kids will
tell Biden and his friends in Washington
stop hurting our children
turn on your TV here in the U.S and it
has been back to back political ads that
often make misleading claims they're
online too now more than ever a
nonpartisan group that tracks political
advertising called ad impact is
calculated that spending on political
ads in 2022 in the U.S is on Pace to
reach 9.7 billion dollars it has never
been that high not even in the last
presidential election politics here is a
winner takes all game someone who thinks
differently from you is not just wrong
they are the enemy earlier today I spoke
with a writer who says that is alien to
the heart of democratic theory that you
can change Minds not through fear but
through persuasion
the persuaders at the front lines of the
fight for hearts minds and democracy is
the title of Anan girdadas's latest book
He's a former foreign correspondent and
columnist and he is with me from
Brooklyn New York hi there on you know
persuasion and politics is what
campaigning I think used to be about
convincing voters that your ideas about
social services taxes whatever to make
your community better but in 2022 I've
talked to so many people here who say
they don't even talk politics with their
family or friends because it inflames
such anger what's your assessment of the
state of the United States right now
well the the United States is in a
really big uh pickle because democracy
itself is uh being tested in this
country as it has only been in in truly
intense moments uh in American history
right now one of the two major political
parties is essentially running
to sabotage the practice of democracy
itself and that's the modern Republican
party that is running on a platform of
white racial resentment male grievance
and having to live in an egalitarian
world and trying to you know overturn
the will of the people in in many
contests across the country and advocate
for political violence as a normal way
to kind of get the world you want so in
that context it is as important if not
more important than ever for those on
the pro Freedom Pro democracy side the
Democratic party and its allies in the
United States to be able to persuade and
you're right it has gotten harder and so
what is the Playbook if you can condense
it I mean you are offering some hope uh
that you know how to work to bridge
divisions to find common ground
how do you do it
well I think the
anti-democracy movement the fascist
movement increasingly in the United
States is actually quite good at
understanding human beings as we
actually are and building a Politics on
top of a realistic sense of how people
form their opinions what their emotional
response to the news is what their fears
and anxieties are and in many ways what
the persuaders book is arguing for is
for pro Freedom pro-democracy forces in
this country to become better at a
human-centered politics I think there's
a notion of being willing to pick fights
it's another part of the persuaders
Playbook being willing to pick righteous
fights uh with all due respect to
Michelle Obama who some years ago said
when they go low we go high I don't know
I think it's also possible to say you
know when they go low we hit harder so
let me ask you why you think that has
not happened on the Democratic side the
Republicans as you say have been good at
commanding attention may be better and
sort of meeting people where they're at
why are the Democrats up till now drop
the ball on that
I think it's a very good question I
think it's a high-mindedness and I think
it comes from a good place at some deep
level I think there's a sense that
there's a belief in citizens that is
kind of almost like a classical like
ancient Greek idea of citizens I think
Democrats have in the US gotten into a
pattern of
imagining who they wished voters were
and speaking to that high-minded person
in a kind of policy language a wonky
language and not really being a guttural
party not not able to speak to the gut
not able to speak to the reptile brain
and looking down on things like
storytelling you know looking down on
things like message as being unnecessary
we need a real Renaissance on the
political left if if we are going to
out-compete Fascism and seize the age
and deliver people the future of nice
things that we deserve and on gear
dardardos thanks
he did have a lot more to say you can
watch the full interview online on our
website globalnews.ca global national
that is our newscast for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen thanks for watching
for now good night from Washington D.C
[Music]
foreign
[Music]